the dark knight is transported to a
mysterious island with no memory
forced to fight an infinite loop of
battles with strange new foes can he
uncover the shocking truth behind the
chaos
batman fortnite
zero point
hey dc fans it's me jim lee dc publisher
and chief creative officer can't wait to
share all of the exciting content we
have in store for you at dc fandom 2021
as you saw in the opening trailer this
year dc and epic games teamed up to
create batman fortnite zero point a
never before seen experience that
brought the world of fortnite and its
characters to comic books for the first
time
this sixth history series is available
now as a hardcover graphic novel
collection fans got an extra bonus in
each issue in the form of a code that
could be redeemed for special dc themed
in-game items for fortnite from the
harlequin rebirth outfit to the armored
batman zero outfit fans got great
content to deck out their characters for
their next match in combining these two
immersive worlds both dc and epic games
knew that there will be more stories to
be told and i'm happy to announce that
we'll be continuing with a new one-shot
crossover called batman fortnite
foundation number one which arrives in
combo shops on tuesday october 26th
i'll be there as soon as i can superman
don't let anyone go through that rivet
easy for you to say
i'm picking up energy from the zero
point here in gotham
you're going to tell me who you are
how you got here
and what you think you're doing in my
city
batman fortnite foundation a special
one-shot comic event wow what a trailer
that was amazing
batman fortnite foundation number one is
also launching simultaneously in nine
countries introducing this character
into the worlds of dc and fortnite is a
big task luckily dc is meeting the
challenge by bringing in some great
storytellers for this one shot
epic games chief creative officer donald
mustard and zero point series writer
christos gage are being joined by the
guy that really knows his way around the
dc universe scott snyder
art will be provided by joshua hixson
and roman stevens in addition to the
awesome cover by scott's partners in
crime greg capullo and jonathan glappian
you can check with your local comic book
store to pre-order these incredible
variant covers one by alex garner and a
premium variant cover featuring art by
donald mustard all this amazing work
edited by the amazing katie cooper and
on tuesday october 26th epic will be
launching the batman who laughs outfit
into the fortnite item shop and in
keeping with dc epic games tradition
with batman fortnite foundation number
one
each print version of the comic will
feature a bonus code redeemable for the
exclusive batman who laughs loading
screen in fortnite we want to thank the
incredible dc and fortnite communities
for all your amazing support your
excitement and enthusiasm are what make
collaborations like this possible
[Music]
you